T'as 24h pour t'inscrire sur les listes électorales
pour les élections européennes.
On t'explique pourquoi c'est important.
Petit 1, comme tu le sais,
il y a beaucoup de pays qui sont en
train de se radicaliser
et grâce à ton vote,
tu pourras faire barrage à l'extrême droite.
Petit 2, on pourra
maintenir et développer les investissements en
direction des jeunes,
petit 3, on pourra financer l'éducation,
la santé,
les transports, l'entrepreneuriat mais aussi l'écologie
et petit 4, on pourra sauvegarder de la lutte
contre les discriminations et le racisme
au niveau européen.
Bref, tout ça pour te dire que ton vote
est important pour faire bouger les choses aujourd'hui
et qu'on en a plus que besoin
jusqu'à demain
pour pouvoir t'inscrire en ligne et pouvoir voter
le neuf/06. Si jamais tu sais pas si tu as inscrit,
tu peux aller vérifier
directement sur je vérifie ma situation électorale.
Et si jamais
t'as pas le temps de t'inscrire d'ici demain,
n'hésite pas à t'inscrire en mérite,
tu as jusqu'au 3 mai